à minuit des dizaines de personnes s'en
prennent au supermarché près du beffroi
les propriétaires tentent de joindre la
police en vain les pompiers sont pris à
partie et font demi-tour alors les deux
directeurs du magasin et quelques
riverains vont eux-mêmes éteindre les
rayons incendiés la crainte un incendie
généralisé de l'enseigne qui se trouve à
proximité d'une station-service parmi
les pilleurs des hommes déguisés en
policiers municipaux car quelques
minutes plus tôt c'est le poste de
police municipale du beffroi qui a été
dégradé et pillée pour les habitants
c'est l'exaspération donc
c'est un peu une révolte pour rien quoi
tout péter je pense que ça a aucun sens
en fait par exemple
des leaders
en hommage d'une autre manière que
casser les choses des gens parce que les
gens ils se réveillent le matin ils
trouvent pas leur voiture les dégâts
matériels sont lourds au beffroi
l'entrée de la mairie annexe et celle de
la médiathèque ont été saccagés tous les
abribus du quartier sont cassés et
plusieurs voitures ont été brûlées le
patron de l'auto-école voisine a perdu
deux véhicules
gendarmerie porter plainte après j'ai
j'ai appelé le dépanneur et puis là je
m'occupe de remplacer les véhicules quoi
ça m'a demandé du temps voilà
faire de l'activité assez conséquente
dans le magasin d'optique plus une paire
de lunettes au bureau de tabac le rideau
de fer est éventré toute la journée les
services municipaux ont tenté d'effacer
les stigmates de cette nuit de violence